this street food dish packs a wonderful
Indian influence subtly spiced chicken
wrap
grab a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken crack open
cardamom pods and add
ground ginger
coriander
cinnamon
grated nutmeg
clove of garlic
fresh coriander
lemon juice
olive oil
and seasoning
now pulverize to form a paste
[Music]
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
some marinade for up to two hours
[Music]
to cook griddle on a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
[Music]
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle
then simply slice your chicken
and put your wrap together
with shredded cabbage
[Applause]
chopped spring onion
and your favorite chili sauce
[Music]
ready in 20 minutes sticky succulent and
utterly Moorish spiced chicken wrap my
next dish uses super fine Fila pastry
and as a variation on a Moroccan classic
easy chicken pastilla
[Music]
first chop onions
Ginger then fry them in hot olive oil
add cinnamon and to give the mix a
subtle sweet note a pinch of sugar
then seasoned chopped cooked chicken
thighs and add to the mix pour in
chicken stock and then simmer
Stone hole lightly beaten eggs which
thicken the sauce and cook
add in sliced almonds
and set aside to cool
now build your pastilla phyllo is
another pastry that's tricky to make at
home but you can buy Fantastic phyllo so
cheese brush each sheet with melted
butter and lay four sheets into a
greased baking tin
[Music]
spoon in half of the Fantastic aromatic
chicken filling
add four more butter sheets of filo
pastry
and simply Pile in the rest of the
delicious chicken
finally cover with a couple of sheets of
phyllo and fold over all the drape sides
brush with more butter
then bake in a hot oven for 10 to 15
minutes
until the top is crispy and golden brown
you want all the Fila paste wonderfully
crunchy and golden so turn over and
return for another 10 minutes
[Music]
when done remove and for a different but
delicious sweet Finishing Touch dust
lightly with icing sugar and cinnamon
intensely aromatic sweet and savory
crispy and succulent and extraordinary
pie that has to be tasted to be believed
[Music]
three types of pastry
three mouth-watering fillings three more
recipes you can stake your life on
so simple to do
beautiful
my next easy slow cook recipe is
incredible spicy Szechuan chicken thighs
[Music]
first marinade the thighs with soy sauce
and shouting wine which is made from
fermented rice and tastes similar to dry
sherry
chicken thighs do a lot of work so they
need more cooking but cook properly
they're moist and are the tastiest part
of the bird next add rice vinegar water
then season and leave to marinade for up
to two hours
then chop garlic
chili and Ginger
add olive oil to a hot pan and Fry it'll
softened add Szechuan peppercorns and
orange zest
next add the marinated chicken thighs
along with a marinade
then throw in a pinch of sugar and Fry
the chicken into as lovely and brown and
the sauce is deliciously thick
finished with chopped spring onions I'd
like a soy sauce and a few drops of
sesame seed oil
marinated for flavor sweet and spicy
chicken a fuss-free Wonder
first up chicken with garlic and
Chestnut stuffing packed with flavor and
earthy richness
[Music]
for the stuffing fry finely chopped
onion garlic
celery in hot olive oil
next add pine nuts which have a lovely
creamy taste and chopped earthy cooked
chestnuts both add a wonderfully chewy
texture and richness to stuffings season
and add chopped parsley
[Music]
then stirring cooked wild rice
next take a whole deboned chicken it's
fiddly to do at home but if you ask your
butcher will do it for you and pile the
stuffing mixture along the center now
simply roll the chicken up tightly and
tie it with your butcher's string
then roast in a hot oven for just over
an hour
[Music]
simply carve into magnificent thick
slices so impressive so easy and trust
me this is a dish guaranteed to get a
fantastic reaction on any occasion